WE WILL BE BACK TOMORROW AND
TUCKER CARLSON IS COMING UP
NEXT, DON’T GO AWAY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME
THIS SPRING TALKING ABOUT
VIRUSES AND HOW THEY SPREAD.
ONE PERSON INFECTS ANOTHER
PERSON WHO INFECTS A THIRD WHO
THEN HAS CONTACT WITH THE LARGER
GROUP OF PEOPLE AND INFECTS 20
MORE, EACH OF WHOM, AND YOU KNOW
HOW IT WORKS, IT’S EXPONENTIAL.
PRETTY SOON, INDIVIDUALS
THOUSANDS OF MILES FROM THE
SOURCE OF THE OUTBREAKS ARE
GETTING SICK.
WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS THE
CRAZINESS SPREADS VERY MUCH THE
SAME WAY.
A SINGLE LUNATIC TO PASS CASE OF
IT TO MILLIONS OF OTHERS.
HYSTERIA IS THE MOST
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE KNOWN TO
MAN.
AND WE ARE NOW LIVING THROUGH A
PANDEMIC OF IT.
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND AMENDMENT
NAMED GEORGE FLOYD DIED IN
POLICE CUSTODY IN MINNESOTA AND
THAT’S WHERE THIS OUTBREAK FIRST
BEGAN.
AND HERE’S THE STATE OF THE
PANDEMIC NOW.
>> IT WAS JUST BEFORE MIDNIGHT
THURSDAY WHEN PROTESTERS BEGAN
DISMANTLING AND TOPPLING A
STATUE HONORING CHRISTOPHER
COLUMBUS AND CIVIC CENTER PARK.
CREWS MOVED IN AND IT DESTROYED
WHAT WAS LEFT.
ONE PROTESTER IS CLIMBING UP A
STATUE AND BEGAN SPRAY PAINTING
ITS FACE AND HANDS POSSIBLY A
CIVILIZING BLOOD UP WHILE OTHERS
SPRAY-PAINTED THE WORDS GEORGE
FLOYD WITH THE WORDS OF BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND THE COMMUNIST
SYMBOL.
THE STATUE HAS BEEN HERE SINCE
1931.
>> Tucker: SO TO TRANSLATE
WHAT YOU JUST SAW INTO THE
CLINICAL LANGUAGE OF
EPIDEMIOLOGY, HOLY SMOKES, THIS
IS GETTING REALLY CRAZY.
WHAT DOES CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
HAVE TO DO WITH GEORGE FLOYD?
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS WAS NOT A
MINNEAPOLIS POLICE OFFICER,
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS WAS AN
ITALIAN NAVIGATOR.
THEY HAVEN’T EVEN HEARD OF
GEORGE FLOYD.
WHO KNOWS, YOU ARE DEFINITELY
NOT ALLOWED TO ASK.
A PATIENT MAY APPEAR TO BE
RECOVERING FROM HYSTERIA,
SPEAKING IN NEARLY COMPLETE
SENTENCES AND BATHING
INDEPENDENTLY ON OCCASION BUT
THEN A SINGLE DIRECT QUESTION
MOST OF THEM INTO A TAILSPIN, A
RENEWED ATTACK OF ANARCHIST
GRAFFITI AND HOURS OF HOSTILE
TWEETING.
IT’S SAFER NOT TO SAY A WORD.
THAT SEPARATELY THE POLICY OVER
AT THE CENTER OF REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE ON CAPITOL HILL.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS HAVE DECIDED
NOT TO DISTURB THE PATIENTS IN
ANY WAY EVEN AS THEY RAMPAGED
THROUGH AMERICA DESTROYING OUR
CULTURE AND HISTORY.
IT’S EASIER TO GIVE THEM WHAT
THEY WANT SO THAT’S WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
RON JOHNSON AND JAMES LANKFORD
ARE BOTH REPUBLICAN SENATORS AND
TODAY THEY ISSUED LEGISLATION TO
ABOLISH COLUMBUS DAY.
THEY WANT TO DELETE IT FROM THE
NATIONAL COUNTER IMPLICIT WITH
JUNETEENTH.
THIS IS A BIG CHANGE.
AMERICANS HAVE CELEBRATE
COLUMBUS DAY AS LONG AS WE HAVE
HAD A COUNTRY’S IN 1792.
THAT’S A CELEBRATION OF THE
NATION ITSELF WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE A NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
THREE WEEKS AGO MANY PEOPLE HAD
NEVER HEARD OF IT, EVEN THE
MEDIA SEEMED OBLIVIOUS TO ITS
EXISTENCE.
FROM 2012 THROUGH 2017, CNN DID
NOT MENTION THE WORD JUNETEENTH
A SINGLE TIME ON THE AIR.
BARACK OBAMA WHO WAS THE
PRESIDENT NEVER TWEETED ABOUT
JUNETEENTH ONCE DURING THE
ENTIRE SPAN OF HIS PRESIDENCY,
NOT ONE TIME.
JUNETEENTH COMMEMORATES THE
FREEING OF THE AMERICAN AND
EMANCIPATION IS ONE OF THE GREAT
MOMENTS IN AMERICA’S HISTORY
WHICH IS WHY WE CONSIDER
ABRAHAM LINCOLN A HERO.
BUT PARADOXICALLY, AND THIS IS
AUDIT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PUSHING
JUNETEENTH ON THE COUNTRY DO NOT
CONSIDER ABRAHAM LINCOLN A HERO.
THEY ARE PULLING DOWN THE
STATUES ALONG WITH COLUMBUS.
CONFUSED?
THAT’S THE NATURE OF HYSTERIA
OUTBREAK, THEY MAKE STEAKS DUMB
ACCENTS.
JOHN LANGFORD DESCRIBES
THEMSELVES AS CONSERVATIVES, AS
IMPROBABLE AS THAT MAY SEEM IN
ON SOME LEVEL THEY MAY SUSPECT
THAT ALL THE YELLING ABOUT
COLUMBUS DAY AND JUNETEENTH
DOESN’T HAVE MUCH TO DO ABOUT
EMANCIPATION WITH CIVIL RIGHTS
AND IS LIKELY JUST ANOTHER WAY
TO HUMILIATE AND DEMORALIZE
AMERICANS.
ON SOME LEVEL THEY KNOW THAT
THEY ARE IGNORING IT WHICH IS
EASIER TO DO WITH HYSTERIA
PATIENTS COME.
UNLESS OF COURSE THE VOTERS
NOTES THEM DOING IT.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
SENATOR MIKE BRAUN OF INDIANA
SPONSORED A BILL DESIGNED TO
PUNISH THE POLICE.
AT THE VERY MOMENT THE COUNTRY
WAS UNDERGOING WIDESPREAD
LOOTING, ARSON AND VIOLENCE.
THEN HE ENDORSED THE RADICAL
RACIAL SEPARATIST BLM MOVEMENT.
AT FIRST THAT CONSTITUENTS
DIDN’T SEEM TO REALIZE THEIR
SENATOR HAD DONE ANY OF THIS BUT
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THEY WERE
ENRAGED AND THEY LET HIM KNOW
ABOUT IT LOUDLY.
MIKE BRAUN IS NOW RUNNING AWAY
FROM HIS OWN BILL.
IF MIKE BRAUN WERE UP FOR
ELECTION THIS YEAR HE WOULD LOSE
LOSE.
SENATORS LANGFORD AND JOHNSON
ARE PRAYING NOTHING LIKE THAT
WILL HAPPEN TO THEM AND THEY ARE
HOPING TO QUIETLY ILLUMINATE
COLUMBUS DAY AND THEN MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT ITEM ON THE WRITER’S
LIST OF DEMANDS.
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO DO THAT?
IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHETHER OR NOT
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT YOU
NOTICED IF THEY ARE TRYING TO
CANCEL COLUMBUS DAY.
IF YOU DON’T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
IT THERE WAS NO TELLING WHAT
JOHNSON AND LANGFORD MIGHT DO
NEXT.
JUST THE OTHER DAY FOR EXAMPLE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" KNOCKS DOWN
GEORGE WASHINGTON STATUTES AND
APPROACHED OUR COUNTRY’S FOUNDER
FROM OUR COLLECTIVE MEMORY.
TODAY THE PAPER ANNOUNCED OF
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER CLOSING
NOT RUSH BECAUSE OF COURSE,
RACISM.
SENATORS JOHNSON AND LANGFORD
HAVE NOT YET ENDORSE THOSE IDEAS
AND AT THIS RATE IT MAY NOT BE
LONG BEFORE THEY DO.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT OTHER
ACTS OF REVOLUTION AND CULTURAL